[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم السي
ابي عاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
واحداث
وتتفاعلوا اخرى هذه الصور تريدنا من
واشنطن حيث عقدت لجنه التحقيق النيابيه
ثقتي حامل الكونجرس جلستها الاخيره قبل
قليل وقد تضمنت توصياتها توجيهها توها من
جنائيه للرئيس السابق
هذا هو المشهد في العاصمه الارجنتينيه
بونس ايريس التي تتاهب لاستقبال المنتخب
الوطني لكره القدم ما الذي يعود من الدوحه
مظفرا بكاس العالم الثالثه في تاريخ
البلاد
وايضا هذه الصور تريدنا من باريس حيث
يستقبل الفرنسيون منتخبهم الوطني الذي حقق
المركز الثاني في المونديال وسيوجه
اللاعبون شكرا للجماهير على دعمهم خلال
البطوله وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
الاوروبيون يتجاوزون خلافا استمر اشهر
ويتفقون على سقف لاسعار الغاز وزراء طاقه
الاتحاد يقرون اليه مرنه تفعل اذا تجاوز
السعر والسقف لثلاثه ايام ومفاوضه الطاقه
تؤكد ان الاليه سيتم ايقافها اذا وجد اثر
سلبي لها وروسيا تقول ان القرار غير مقبول
وتلوح بالرد
في ثالث هجوم خلال اسبوع عشرات المسيارات
الروسيه تضرب العاصمه الاوكرانيه زنسكي
يطالب قاده غربيين بزياده الامدادات
العسكريه لا سيما الدفاعات الجويه وبوتين
يبحث في بيلاروسيا انشاء مجال دفاعيا
موحدا بين موسكو
في ختام عام ونصف من التحقيقات واكثر من
1000 مقابله لجنه التحقيق في اقتحام
الكونجرس توصي وزاره العدل الامريكيه
بملاحقه ترامب جنائيا باربعها من بينها
التمرد وتؤكد ان تقديرها النهائي سينشر
قبل نهايه العام
بعد انتخابات تشريعيه سجلت ادنى مشاركه في
تاريخ تونس هيئه الانتخابات تؤكد ان نسبه
التصويت بلغت نحو احد عشر في المئه ونائب
رئيسها يقولوا ان دعوه المعارضه الى
المقاطعه اثرت بشكل كبير ومركز كارتر
الدولي لمراقبه الانتخابات يقولوا ان
الاقترا يفتقر الى الشرعيه
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تصويت مستخدمي تويتر لصالح
تنحي الى مصر عن الرئاسه التنفيذيه للمنصه
التي يملكها وذلك في استطلاع اطلقه
البلياردير مساء الاحد عبر المنصه حسب
النتائج فقط صوت اكثر من 57% لصالح تخلي
ماسك عن رئاسه تويتر لتطلعي ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي ما الذي يعني هذا الاستفتاء لتويتر
وكيف سينعكس على سياسه النشر والاشراف على
المحتوى بالمنصف توقع 34% تغيير الاداره
والتراجع عن الاجراءات الجديده بينما توقع
سبعه وثلاثون في المئه تنحي ماسك فقط عن
الاداره دون تغيير في التوجهات واشار 29%
الى بقاء الوضع على ما هو عليه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربي
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
تابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
في ختام كاس العالم قطر 2022 رسائل ثقافيه
وحضاريه في نسخه عربيه استثنائيه من
المونديال رغم حملات التشكيك
واضل سقرتنا في المتابعه نصلي الضوء على
سجالات وخلافات ترسيم الحدود البحريه في
المتوسط بعد قرار مصر ترسيم حدودها
البحريه الغربيه ورفض حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه الليبيه لها
[موسيقى]
اذا بعد اشهر من الاخذ والرد ومع دخول فصل
الشتاء يتجاوز الاوروبيون اخيرا خلافاتهم
بشان تحديد سعر الغاز بعد اقرار اليه
وصفها بالمرينه واعلن نائب رئيس الوزراء
تشيكي اتفاق وزراء الطاقه الاوروبيين على
تحديد السقف لسعر الغاز وعلى اليه التنفيذ
كذلك وقال الوزير تشيكي ان الاتفاق سيء
يفعل بشكل الالي اذا استمر سعر الغاز لمده
ثلاثه ايام في تجاوز حاجز المئه وثمانين
يورو لكل ميغاواتا في الساعه من جانبها
قالت مفاوضات الاتحاد لشؤون الطاقه
جاهز لايقاف اليه تسعير الغاز اذا رات
المؤسسات الماليه اثرا سلبيا على الاسواق
اما روسيا المستهدفه بالقرار فوصفته بغير
المقبول مؤكده انها تتخذ القرار
سبسك
قبل حرب روسيا عهد اوكرانيا كانت الدول
الاوروبيه تشتري الغاز بصوره جماعيه
للحصول على اسعار الافضل كانت روسيا
المزوده الرئيسيه للقاره لكنها خفضت
امداداتها من الغاز في اعقب الحرب تحول
الاعتماد الاوروبي الى دول اخرى في العالم
ابرزها الولايات المتحده فارتفعت اسعار
الغازي في منازل الاوروبيين بشكل قياسي
يسعى القاده الاوروبيون الان الى تخفيض
فاتوره الغاز في منازل المواطنين لكنه
مختلف لشهور على تحديد اسعار الغاز اتفق
الاوروبيون اليوم على سقف سعر لا يتجاوزوا
180 يورو لكل ميغاوات في الساعه يعني ذلك
انتهاء خلافات استمرت لشهور اذا كانت
المانيا وهولندا والنمس واخرون يتحفظون
على الفكره من اساسها ويخشون من اي يمتنع
من تجول الغاز عن ارسال الوقود والاتجاه
الى زبائن اخرين تهدد موسكو على الدوام
بالرد على محاولات الاوروبيين تحديدا
السقف لسعر وهو رد بتاعتها منطارا الان
تقول اوروبا انها خفضت اعتمادها على الغاز
الروسيه من 49% الى سبعه في المئه من
اجمالي احتياجاتها بهذا تطوي اوروبا شهور
من الخلاف على تحديد السقف لسعر الغاز
لكنها لا تنهي ازمه التوفره في منازل
الاوروبيين وهم ينتظرون شتاءا قد يكون
قاسيا
حول هذا الموضوع معنا
اسواق الغاز بمؤسسه ريستاد انرجي
للاستشارات الطاقه ومن موسكو معنى
الباحث في الشؤون الاقتصاديه والعلاقات
الدوليه اهلا بكما سند ماذا سيحقق هذا
الاجراء الاوروبي
يا سوسو
الهدف هو ان الذي هو حمايه
الاسواق الاوروبيه من ارتفاع عالي في
الاسعار وقد كنا نواجه هذا الامر وخاصه في
شهر اغسطس و سبتمبر تجاوزت الاسعار 300
يورو
ميغاوات بالتالي الهدف وهو تهيئه وحمايه
الدول الاوروبيه من الصدمات التي قد
تواجهها الاسواق
من يلزم هذا هذا الاتفاق غير الدول
الاوروبيه
اذا الاهم هو لاوروبا ولا الدول الاوروبيه
ايضا
هنالك بعض الاختلافات في بالنسبه لمن
يدعمه او لا تلقى بعض الانتقادات هنالك
بوعد قلق حول مسالتي تاثير هذا الامر على
الاسعار وقد يؤثر على الاقتصادات ايضا لكن
هذه روعه القلق هذه قد لا تبدو انها بدايه
الاهميه
على روسيا
من المثيره للاهتمام معرفه اذا ما كانت
روسيا سيكون رد فعل على هذه الاله
الاوروبيه ام لا تم الاعلان الرسميه من
الحكومه الروسيه بان روسيا ستقوم بايقاف
بيع الغاز الى الاتحاد الاوروبي اذا ما
كان هنالك وضع اليسقفنا على الاسعار لكن
ربما بطريقه ما فانه تم تصميم هذه الاليه
لن يتم النظر اليها على انها تتطلب رد فعل
من روسيا لانه هنالك الكثير من الامور غير
الواضحه حول عمليه حول عمل هذه الاليه
مثلا هنالك ليا لقاء الذاتي لهذا السقف
على الاسعار اذا ماتجاوزه
هذا السعر المستهلكين الاوروبيين مثلا
منتجيه الغاز المسال يوقف وبيع الغاز الى
اوروبا في هذه الحاله قد تكون الاليه
ضعيفه جدا او غير قويه للاستدعاء رد فعل
روسيا لكن باست انا تخيل بان هذه الا يمكن
تقويه هذه الاليه وقد تؤثر على
عقود بين مثلا همم روسيا والشركاء
الاوروبيه في هذه الحاله قد يكون هنالك
ايقاف لتدفق الغاز لكن اعتقد انها هذه
امور يجب ان ننتظر لن نراها مستقبلا في
حال اوقفت روسيا التماما بيع الغاز الى
اوروبا الان ياتي هذا الاجراء بنتيجه
عكسيه لما هو متوقع منه
يعني انا اعطيك فلوس
ذكرها الضيف الاخر انها في حتى هذه اللحظه
نحن لا نرى اي تاثير على هذه
الاليه
وتاثيرها على الاسعار لكن في حالتي
هنالك ربما
اضطرابات على وضع الاوساق في اوروبا اعتقد
اننا باستطاعاتنا قد تمنع ارتفاع الاسعار
بشكل كبير لكن بدون
ليس هنالك حسب السوق الحالي ليس هنالك الى
مخاطر مرئيه وكما قلت فان وضع السوق هل
هذا وضع السوق الحالي وبامكانه ان يتغير
مستقبلا
هل سيكون الرد الروسي كما ذكرت لنا بوقفي
بيع الغاز تماما لاوروبا هل هذا هو همم
الرد
اعتقد ان روسيا باستطاعتها ان توقف بيع
الغاز الى اوروبا فقط في حاله ان هذه
الاليه قد تم
تقويتها اذا ما تخيلنا سيناريو انه هنالك
هذا الامر سيؤثر على العقود الحاليه لانه
بحسب تصميمها الان هي لا لن تؤثر على
الاقتصاديه الاوروبيه بشكل عام في لكن يتم
استخدامها في ظروف
معينه اذا ما كانت الاسعار مثلا تجاوزت
تجاوزت بشكل اسعاره بشكل كبير لكن اذا ما
اختلف الوضع بالنسبه للغاز مستقبلا واذا
ما كان هنالك هنالك ظروف كثيره وشروط
كثيره لكن اذا ما تم تقويه هذه اعتقد
نظريا انه كان روسي الغاز الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي وحسب رايي سيكون ذلك اسئله كبيره
حول كيفيه
بالنسبه للدول التي تبيع الغاز ايضا في
انحاء العالم بامكاني ان يكون لديها رد
فعل اتجاه هذا الامر اضعوا انفسكم باي همم
خبيرا للغاز او في الدول الشرق الاوسط او
في امريكا اللاتينيه او في افريقيا ما
الذي سيقومون به اذا ما قالوا انه الامر
يعود للاتحاد الاوروبي لكي يحددوا
السعر الذي يدفعونه لتلك الدول التي تبيع
الغاز ولا يعتمدون على اسعار السوق
اعتقدوا ان هذا الامر بامكانه ان يدمر
العلاقات بين الاتحاد الاوروبيه بين الدول
بين الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول مثل اذربيجان
والجزائر مثلا شكرا لك
البحث في الشؤون الاقتصاديه والعلاقات
الدوليه من موسكو وشكرا لضيفنا من اوسلو
سند محلل اسواق الغاز بمؤسست انرجي الطاقه
[موسيقى]
تعرضت العاصمه الاوكرانيه لسلسله هجمات
خلال اسبوع صعدت فيه مواقع
تضررت وحرمت سكان العاصمه وضواحيها من
الكهرباء
الى زياده الامدادات العسكريه لبلاده لا
سيما دفاعات الجويه اما الرئيس الروسي
فاكد خلال زيارته الى بيلاروسيا انه بحث
انشاء مجال دفاعيا موحدا بين موسكو وميسي
فيسبوك
المسيرات ثالث هجوم من روسي في اقل من
اسبوع على العاصمه الاوكرانيه لقد لقلت
السلطات المحليه لكن الاضرار الماديه طالت
البنت التحتيه واغرقت المدينه وضواحيها
الى كهرباء تتحدث روايه الاداره العسكريه
عن اسقاط الدفاعاتها 25 من اصل عشرين
مسيره رصدت في سمائك وكالعاده اتهمت
السلطات المحليه ايران بتزويد روسيا
بطائرات بدون طيار من نوع شاهد وبانها
اطلقت هذه المره من الساحل الشرقي للبحر
ازوف عوده الهجمه الروسيه على كيف بعد
انقطاع عندما فتره هل ستغير شيئا في خريطه
المعارك المتاثره بالمناخ وبامور اخرى
خريطه لا تعرف تغيير لافتا يعززه جبهه طرف
على حساب اخر
نزيد ثم المزيد من الاسلحه الجمله شبه
اليوميه للرئيس زيلينسكي وهو يدلي بتصريح
او يخاطب اجتماعا لحلفاء بلاده وما اكثر
الاجتماعات والقمم منذ نشوب هذه الحرب هذا
اجتماع الدول الاعضاء في تحالف قوه
الاستطلاع المشتركه الذي تقوده بريطانيا
ان عقد في ريغا بلاتيا وفي جدول الاعمال
مناقشه جهود مواجهه العدوان الروسي وصفهم
قائمه مطالب الرئيس الاوكراني واضحه دع
بريطانيا الى زياده الامدادات من الدفاعات
الجويه والمساعده في تسريع قرارات الشركاء
بهذا الشان وطلب منه هولندا تزويد بلاده
بالدبابات خلال المناقشات حتى رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناتا قاده دول
التحالف عن الابقاء على مستويات العام
الجاري من الدعم لاوكرانيا او زيادتها
خلال عام 2023 مستوى الخشيه من الاهداف
غير المعلنه لزي الرئيس الروسي بلاط
المربوط اللي ماسك في هذا التوقيت بلا عذر
وتحت ضمن الوفد الرفيع وزير الدفاع
والخارجيه الصور التي نشرتها وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه لمناورات عسكريه مشتركه مع
بلاروسيا تعزز مخاوف الغرب من انضمام قوات
الحليف لكشينكو الى الحرب الدائره الامر
ليس كذلك رد المتحدث باسم الكربلا على
الاصوات المحذره من ذلك السيناريوم وصف
التلميح الى ان موسكو تضغط على مسك
للمشاركه في العمليه العسكريه الخاصه بانه
فبركه غبيه الاسد
رومانسيه شبه منعدمه والمواقف كقصى
المنطقه مجمده ولن تذوب قريبا مسلسل حرب
روسيا في اوكرانيا مستمرا لغايه 2000
وثلاث 2023
[موسيقى]
الى الولايات المتحده فقط صوتت لجنه
التحقيق الخاصه باقتحام الكونجرس لصالح
يرفع توصيات باربعه من جنائيه بحق الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب لوزاره العدل
الامريكيه
تتمثلتهم بعرقله عمل الكونجرس والتامر على
الاحتلال على الحكومه الامريكيه
والتامر لتقديم تصريحات كاذبه والتمرد وقد
انهت اللجنه تحقيقها الموسع الذي امتد
لنحو عام ونصف عام ومن المقرر ان ينشر
التقرير النهائي الاربعاء المقبل
من مقر الكونجرس معنا مراسله الجزيره
بيسان ابو كويك بيسان ما معاني هذا
الاجراء وكيف يتوقع ان ينعكس على المستقبل
السياسي ليترون
السي طبعا هذا الاجراء ربما بشكل عام هو
اجراء رمزي بما ان هذه اللجنه ليست لديها
الصلاحيه ولا للكونجرس مثل هذه الصلاحيات
بالتوجيه هذه التهام رسميه لذا فهي توصيات
رفعت لوزاره العدل الان يقع الامر على
عاتق الوزاره والمحقق الخاص جاكسون الذي
عينه وزير العدل المالكي قبل عده اشهر
اما بتوجعها او الاستفاده من
الوثائق الاف الصفحات من الوثائق التي
طبعا نتوقع ان تصدر خلال التقرير الذي
سيصدر يوم الاربعاء الشهادات ساعات وساعات
من الشهادات التي جماعتها هذه اللجنه
والادله على مدار 18 شهرا من تحقيقاتها
ولكن الوزاره ليست ملزمه بالعمل بتوجيه
هذه التهاب ولكن بشكل عام هذه وتاريخيه
ايضا هذه لاول مره توجه او ترفع توصيات
لوزاره العدل بتوجيه تهم جنائيه فيدراليه
بحق رئيسا سابق لذا التوقعات هنا ومما
سمعناها ايضا من اعضاء اللجنه خلال هذه
الجلسه لان التصرفات ترامب يوم السادس من
يناير ان كان بدفعه بشكل مباشر وهمم يعني
على درايه بالكذب همم باتزاعم تزوير
الانتخابات ومن ثم محاولات قلب النتيجه
قبل الانتخابات ومن ثم حظ ما اسمته اللجنه
واعضاؤها الغاء علاقتها عام الكعبه وجلوس
كما قالت النائبه لستيني نائبه رئيس
اللجنه لمده ساعات داخل البيت الابيض
يتعرض للاقتحام فهذا يجعل ان هذا اي شخص
يتصرف بهذه الطريقه لا يمكن ان يتولى
السلطه في منصب حكومي رسمي ولا يؤهله
لاتولي الرئاسه من جديد لذا هناك رمزيه
كبيره ولكن هناك سيكون على الاغلب وقع
سياسي خصوصا واننا بدانا نسمع بشكل متزايد
الان من اصوات جمهوريه مثلا في مجلس
الشيوخ متش مكانل الذين يعتبرون ترامب غير
مؤهل لتولي الرئاسه من جديد طبعا حتى الان
ننتظر رد فعل اساسي من ترامب ولكنه كان
قبل جلسه اللجنه اليوم
بالامس عبر موقعه روسوشل طبعا هاجمها هاجم
مجريات هذه التحقيقات خصوصا وان
الجمهوريين من حلفاء ترامب في الكونجرس
يعتبرون ان عمل هذه الجلسه كان عمل عفوا
اللجنه عمل حزبي همم بامتياز وهناك
تسريبات تقول ان الجمهوريين
ينون يوم الاربعاء بدورهم ايضا نشر تقرير
مضاد لتقرير لجنه السادس من يناير وكما
تعلم
هذه اللجنه الان تنهي عملها هذا الكونجرس
بصيغته الحاليه ينتهي عمله مع نهايه هذا
العام مع مطلع العام المقبل سيستلم
الجمهوريون ضفاف السلطه او يعني القياده
في مجلس النواب وربما نتوقع تحقيقات اخرى
من على شكل اخر في مجلس النواب تصب في
الاتجاه المعاكس وكان الجمهوريين طلبوا
بابقاء جميع الادله والمواد والشهادات
متوفره من هذه اللجنه لانهم يريدها
تحقيقات اخرى حين يستلموا شكرا القياده
شكرا لك بلسان ابو كويك مراسلتنا من مقر
الكوميس
الى تونس حيث اعلنت الهيئه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات بتونس ان نسبه
المشاركه في الانتخابات التشريعيه بلغت 11
في المئه وكان نائب رئيس الهيئه قال ان
دعوات الاحزاب المعارضه لمقاطعه
الانتخابات البرلمانيه اثرت بشكل كبير على
نسبه المشاركه من جهات يعتبرت اطراف
معارضه ان نسبه المشاركه تمثل نهايه
لشرعيه الرئيس بشكل كامل ودعت الى اجراء
انتخابات رئاسيه مبكرا
بما فيها قرارات الالغاء الاصوات بشكل
كامل اماطه الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات اللثام عن نتائج الانتخابات
التشريعيه السابقه لاوانها والتي شهدت
نسبه اقبال هي الاضاف منذ الثوره
[موسيقى]
25 الف
باصواتهم في جميع المكاتب والمراكز بنسبه
اقبال
11.22
الانتخابي الذي انا شرعيه الرئيس سعيد
وهدم المسار الذي اتخذه بعد اجراءات
الخامس والعشرين من يوليو
واصبح الحل من وجهه نظرها هو رحيل الرئيس
عبر التنحي التوعيه او اجراء انتخابات
الرئاسيه
انتخابات رئاسيه السابقه لاوانها
مره اخرى من غير انكار من غير مكابره ابو
قيس سعيد المرضيه يسمع شعبي
الذي شارك في ملاحظه العمليه ان نسبه
الاقبال الضعيفه على التصويت
امل الشعب التونسي
والاقتصادي الحالي
الى ان خريطه الطريق الرئيسيه التي نفذها
الرئيس قيس سعيد لم تنجح في توحيد البلاد
نسبه المشاركه يوم ما يؤكدان الحاجه الى
الشروع في مسار المختلفه لمعالجه امال
الشعب التونسي وتحقيق تطلعاته لديمقراطيه
اكثر شمولا واقتصاد اكثر زهارا
يقول الرئيس قيس سعيد ان جميع قراراته
التي اتخذها جاءت استجابه لاراده الشعب
صاحب السلطه الاصليه
وفي هذه النقطه تحديدا تعتبر المعارضه ان
عزوفا المواطنين عن الذهاب الى الانتخابات
لا يمثل رفضا لبرلمان المنزوع صلاحيات
فحسب بل سحبل للبساط من الرئيس نفسه
تعد الانتخابات التشريعيه احدث حلقه في
سلسله الاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي اخرها
الرئيس قيس سعيد
معتبرا اياها محطه فاصله تصوره لاصلاح
الاوضاع في تونس لكن نسبه الاقبال الضعيفه
دفعت المعارضه الى الترحيل مبادراته
للخروج من ازمه بالغه التعقيد لن تختصر
تداعيتها على الجانب السياسي فحسب سيف
الدين الجزيره
تونس
من تونس ينضموا الينا بلبابه سالم الكاتب
الصحفي مرحبا بك كيف تتوقع سيد سالم ان
يتعامل ان تتعامل الرئاسه التونسيه مع
نتيجه هذه الانتخابات
هذه الانتخابات التي شكلت ربما سياسيا وهي
بثائبه الرساله السياسيه القويه للسلطه
ولراس السلطه اساس الرئيس قيس سعيد هي
الذي رساله
المشروع الذي بشر به الرئيس سعيد او خريطه
الطريقه التي اعلن عنها تقريبا منذ سنه
كانت الانتخابات التشريعيه الحاليه وحتى
الاستفتاء من قبل هي اجابه واضحه وصريحه
من الشعب التونسي خاصه بعد التردد الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه بالطبع هنا هذه
الرساله السياسيه عليه ان يقراها جيدا وان
يقوم بتقييم يعني للمرحله ولم يقرا هذه
النتائج من الزاويه السياسيه اساسا
ان الشعب التونسي ربما الذي طالما تحدث
باسمه هنا وانه يريد تحقيق تطلعاته قد قطع
الانتخابات يعني بهذه النسبه لم تحصل منذ
الاستقلال تقريبا في تونس بعد الثوره يعني
كانت اقل نسبه تقريبا هي 40% ووسط في 2014
حتى 60% نسبه المشاركه التي انتخابات يعني
هذه النسبه الحاليه مقاطعه تقريبا 90% من
الجسم التي
تشكل عزوفا وتشكل رفضا للسياسه الحاليه
دائما السلطه مطالبه بايجاد حلول والسياسي
مطالب بايجاد نتيجه هناك ازمه سياسيه
عميقه هناك ازمه ثقه وهذه الازمه السياسيه
طبعا لا لا تعالج في اطار الا في اطار
الحوار الا في اطار هنا اطار تشاركي لان
المسار الذي اتخذها الرئيس في سعيد هو
مسار فردي ويريد تكريس مشروع فردي عبر ما
يسمى بالبناء القاعدي يرفض الاجسام الو
طيب والحساب
به احزاب المعارضه اكثر من مره ولكن الان
احزاب المعارضه وصلت الى حد المطالبه
بتنحي الرئيس باجراء انتخابات مبكرا همم
انتخابات رئاسيه مبكرا كيف تقيم هذا
الموقف وما السبيل الى تحقيقه باعتقادك
تجربه متميزه يعني العقل السياسي التونسي
مثلا سنه 2013
وعندما اشتدت الازمه السياسيه في البلاد
استطاع عبر الحوار الوطني الشهير حين ذلك
الذي رعاه الاتحاد العام التونسي الشغل
وبقيه المنظمات الوطنيه كذلك وجمعت كل
الاحزاب والتيارات السياسيه على الطاوله
الحوار للخروج بخارطه الطريق واضحه لتنهي
تلك الازمه السياسيه ولتدخل البلاد في
مرحله جديده افرزه الانتخابات طبعا رئاسيه
وتشريعيه افرزت البرلمان المنتخب ورئيس
جديدا الان نفس الشيء يعني الرئيس المشكله
ان الحوار الرئيس يرفض الحوار مع معارضيه
هذه المشكله الرئيسه يعني الرئيس يرفض
الحوار مع معارضيه وبالتالي هنا همم وهو
مطالب بالانفتاح الان رئيس قيس سعيد
المطلب بخطوه الى الوراء لابد ان ينفتح
على معارضيه لابد ان يقرا الرساله جيدا لا
مثلا الاتحاد العام توصي شغل في اكثر من
مره ادعى الى حوار وطني جمع الان عليه ان
يستثمر الرئيس هذه الفرصه طبعا المعاني
المعارضه نفسها المعارضه التونسيه مطالبه
ايضا بتوحيد
موقع للاسف في تونس اذا المعارضه المعارضه
صحيح ان المعارضه كلها تقريبا الجبهات
الثلاث الكبرى جبهه الخلاص الوطني الحزب
الحر الدستوري او كذلك مجموعه
لكنها كذلك مطلبون بخارطه الطريق وحتى
يعود الحوار السياسي
[موسيقى]
في فقره المتابعه الليله نصلي الضوء على
اعتماد الرئيس المصري قرارا بشان ترسيم
الحدود البحريه في بلاده مع ليبيا القرار
الذي نشر في الجريده الرسميه نص على ان
تبدا حدود المياه الاقليميه الغربيه لمصر
من نقطه الحدود البريه المصريه الليبيه
رقم واحد ولمسافه 12 ميلا بحريا في عمق
البحر المتوسط قبل القرار باعتراضي ليبيا
حيث اكدت حكومه الدبابه انه ينتهي كومياها
الاقليميه فضلا عن ان مساله ترسيم الحدود
البحريه تتم عبر اتفاق الدولتين لا من
جانبا واحد كما فعلت القاهره
يتداخل خط الحدود المصري هذا جزئيا مع خط
المنطقه البحريه التي تتقاسمها تركيا
تفاهم بينهما عام 2019 لكنه لا يصل الى
الجزء البحري التركي من تلك المنطقه غير
ان الاتفاق الليبيه التركي يصطدم
باعتراضات اليونان التي تقول انه ينتهك
حقوقها ويمثل اعتداء على الجرف القري
لجزيره كريت تندرج وهذه التجاذبات بما
فيها القرار المصري في سياق صراع النفوذ
بين الدول المطله على البحر المتوسط على
اكبر نصيب من موارد الطاقه التي ازدادت
الحاجه اليها بعد حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
السباق الى موارد الطاقه في المتوسط كان
عاملا اساسيا في ابرام اتفاقيات ومذكراتي
تفاهم حول الحدود البحريه خلال السنوات
الاخيره ومن ابرزها
توقيع مصر وقبرص عام 2003 اتفاقيه ترسيم
منطقه الاقتصاديه الخالصه لكل منهما وعام
2019 توصلت تركيا وليبيا الى مذكراتي
تفاهما لترسيم الحدود البحريه قبلت
بانتقادات من الاتحاد الاوروبي ومصر
واليونان وقبرص بعد اقل من عام ابرمت مصر
واليونان اتفاقيه لترسيم حدودهما البحريه
قضت منى مراحلها بتعيين الطرفين المناطق
الاقتصاديه الخالصه لهما
اما احدث اتفاق لترسيم الحدود البحريه
فكان في اكتوبر الماضي بين لبنان واسرائيل
وقد تم بعد سنوات من التفاوض الصعب بواسطه
امريكيه ورعايته الامم المتحده حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الينا من القاهره السفير
حسين هريدي مساعد وزير الخارجيه المصريه
السابق ومن مصراته معنا عبد الباسط
الحداد الخبير القانوني والمحامي لدى
المحكمه العليا
سيد السفير حسين هريدي لماذا تفردت مصر
بترسيم الحدود من دون التنسيق مع ليبيا
يعني هذا الموضوع قانوني موضوع قانوني بحث
ولا ينبغي تسيسه
ومصر في تعيينها لحدودها البحريه
مارست سيادتها الكامله على
اراضيها وعلى
البحر الاقليمي او مياهها الاقليميه
ومصر عندما قدمت على ذلك اقدمت على ذلك في
اطار التزامها وتوقيعها وتصديقها على
اتفاقيه الامم المتحده لقانون البحار التي
تحدد في مواد عده هذه الاتفاقيه بتحدد
كيفيه تعيين تعيين الحدود البحريه
الدول سواء حضرتك المياه الاقليميه او
المنطقه الاقتصاديه
الخالصه او حتى كيفيه تحديد الجرف الجرف
القاري كما تحدد في حاله قيام نزاع كيفيه
كيف يمكن تسويه هذه النزاع بالطرق السلميه
والاتفاقيه بتحدد حضرتك همم الاجراءات
اللي يمكن اللجوء اليها في حاله وجود نزاع
بين دوله او دولتين او اكثر حول تعيين
حدودهم ال- ال- البحريه عندما همم عندما
بنعين حدودنا البحريه وعندما هينحدودنا
البحريه همم اخيرا كما جاء في قرار السيد
رئيس الجمهوريه نحن اعتمدنا حضرتك على
نقاط اثاث وعلامات كما ورد في هذه
الاتفاقيه ونقاط الاساس والعلامات
والاحداثيات تم ايداعها لدى الامين العام
او السكرتير العام للامم المتحده همم وده
يثبت ان ما اقتمت عليه مصر يتفق مع صحيح
القانون الدولي وصحيح الاتفاقيه الامم
المتحده لقانون البحار ما رايك سيد عبد
الباسط حداد
مساء الخير وتحيه طيبه لكم ولكل الساده
المشاهدين بدايه لا يفوتنا نتقدم بالتهنئه
لدوله قطر على النجاح الباهر والتنظيم
الخرافي بطوله كاس العالم ااه اما عن
موضوع الخلاف الليبي المصري المستجد ااا
منذ مستجد هذه الايام بشان المنطقه
الاقتصاديه الخالصه فهذا امر حقيقه همم
يجب ان يتم وفقا لاتفاقيه بين الدولتين
تحديد او ترسيم الحدود
ترسيم الحدود الخاصه بالمنطقه الاقتصاديه
الخالصه نحن جميعا نعرف ان اتفاقيه جمايكا
او اتفاقيه اتفاقيه قانون البحار قانون
المتحده البحار التي وقعت في جمايكا عام
1982 ودخلت حيز همم التنفيذ منذ عام 1994
هي من نظمت سياده الدول على المناطق
البحريه وحق الانتفاع همم كل دوله
بمناطقها المناطق البح كما ذكر الضيف من
مصر ت- تتمثل في همم
المياه الاقليميه ثم المنطقه الاقتصاديه
الخالصه ثم الجرف القاري وما يتبعها من
مناطق اخرى كالخرجي»
عبد الباسط قال لنا انما اقدمت عليه مصر
يتفق مع القانون الدولي وقد اودع لدى
الامم المتحده
في الحقيقه هو هو يقول ذلك لكن ترسيم
الحدود لما تكون في اي اي خلاف بين دولتين
حول ترسيم الحدود او حدود المنطقه
الاقتصاديه الخالصه تكون هناك جهات ربما
يلجا اليها وهذه النصوص عليها في اتفاقيه
قانون البحار منها همم
المحكمه الدوليه لقانون البحار الموجوده
في المانيا في هامبرج لكن همم انا ساوضح
همم جزء بسيط في هذا الخلاف او انما قامت
به قام به رئيس جمهوريه مصر ليس موافقا
للقانون الدولي لان ليبيا وتركيا سبق وان
همم السماء المنطقه الاقتصاديه الخالصه
لكل منهما بموجب مذكر التفاهم مودعه هذه
المذكره في الامم المتحده والقرار الجديد
الذي يرسم حدود مصر او يرسم الحدود
المائيه لمصر في المنطقه الاقتصاديه
الخاصه بها يتداخل مع هذه المنطقه ويسحب
جزء كبير من المنطقه الاقتصاديه الخالصه
طيب وبالتالي كان لا يجب على رئيس مصر ان
ااا يقوم بمثل هذا العمل لان ينتهك
اتفاقيه سابقه بين دولتين عضويا في الامم
المتحده وهذه الاتفاقيه
المتحده وهي جزء من القانون الدولي
الليبيه يتكلم عن حمايه منطقه الصيد
الليبيه صادر العام 2005 هذا القرار همم
يتداخل ايضا مع ما جاء في همم قرار رئيس
الحكومه المصريه بتحديد هذه وبالتالي هناك
همم اعتقد ان هناك جديد حصل من من رئيس
جمهوريه مصر بيمص السياده الليبيه ويمس
المناطق الخاصه بالدول الليبيه
همم
القاهره الان الان هناك هذه الاعتراضات
الليبيه كيف ستعامل معها القاهره
هو بدايه انا احب اوضح حاجه حضرتك يا فندم
اما ليبيا بغض النظر مين بيمثل ليبيا هنا
وانا لن ادخل في الاوضاع من يمثل الشرعيه
في ليبيا
اما ليبيا وقعت
اتفاقيه تعيين حدود البحريه مع تركيا في
نوفمبر 19
ثم كان ساعتها حكومه الوفاق الوطني
السابقه ثم حت منذ حوالي شهر او شهر ونصف
قامت حكومه طرابلس او ما يطلق عليها حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه بتوقيع مذكره تفاهم مع
تركيا
للتنقيب عن النفط والغاز في المنطقه
المنطقه المناطق اللي حددوها كم منطقه
اقتصاديه خالصه ومياه اقليميه ليبيا او من
من يمثل ليبيا لن يستشير مصر
يعني هو قام بتعيين يعني النهارده
ضيفكم من طرابلس بيتهم الحكومه المصريه
والدوله المصريه انها لم ان هي لم تحترف
او انتهت السياده الليبيه احنا لم نفعل
ذلك
وبعدين انا من البدايه بقول ده موضوع
قانوني ومصر بتمارس سيادتها على اا
اراضيها وعلى امتداد اراضيها في المياه
الاقليميه والمنطقه الاقتصاديه
وعلى الجرف القاري تابع لها وفقا لما
حددته
همم ده اول شيء ثاني شيء احنا لا ندخل اذا
كان همم من يمثل الشرعيه في ليبيا مستقبلا
مستقبلا يرى في هذا همم حضرتك انتهاكا
لسياد الليبيه فاء اتفاقيه قانون البحار
بتحدد الوسائل السلميه لتسويه الخلاف بين
دولتين الساحليتين او اكثر في خلاف بينهم
حوالين اولى تعيين مياههم الاقليميه او
المنطقه الاقتصاديه خالصه فبالتالي يعني
احنا لا نرى ان في اي مواجهه بين مصر
وليبيا سواء في الحاضر او في المستقبل لحد
بالنسبه
لهذا الموضوع
مع دول اخرى هذه اول نقطه اثارها سعاده
السفير
وما يحكم هذا الموضوع هو قانون البحار
والقانون الدولي
البحار واتفاقيه جمايكا ل- همم
للبحار نحن لا نختلف في هذا انا وسعاده
السفير المطلق نحن نحتكم الى هذه
الاتفاقيه وهذه القواعد القانون الدولي
لكن ما يقال عن ان ليبيا لم تستشر مصر
ليبيا عندما ابرمت اتفاقيه
لترسيم الحدود المائيه او همم تعيين
المنطقه الاقتصاديه الخالصه ما بين ليبيا
وتركيا همم اضافت لمصر مئات الالاف من
الكيلومترات همم من همم من المياه على
الاتفاقيه التي رمتها مصر مع اليونان مصر
عندما برمت اتفاقيه مع اليونان واعتقد
معها دوله همم اسرائيل همم في تلك
الاتفاقيه الثلاثيه همم كانت حصتها اقل من
اقل مما منحته ليبيا لمصر وفقا للاتفاقيه
التي ابرمتها مع تركيا لكن من هو الذي امر
من الاتفاقيه اولا اولا من هذه الاتفاقيه
واصبح جزءا من القواعد القانوني الدولي
اولا في منظمه الامم المتحده ليبيا قامت
بذلك اولا وبالتالي التصرف حقيقه اللي قام
به رئيس جمهوريه مصر همم مستغرب جدا في
هذه في هذا الوقت يعني ضد ضد
المحكمه العليا من مصراته وشكرا لا السفير
حسين هريدي مساعد وزير الخارجيه المصريه
السابق ضيفنا من القاهره اشكركم على هذه
المشاركه معنا وبهذا مشاهدي مشاهدينا
نصلوا الى نهايه حصاده الليله شكرا
لمتابعتكم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]